arias de enero para volcán con la gran
mayoría de la bancada republicana del
senado incluido el líder republicano
votó para absolver al expresidente trump
firmando sus nombres en las columnas de
la historia junto a su nombre para
siempre forever
jenny willis x el 6 de enero vivirá como
un día de infamia en la historia de eeuu
de américa la no condena de donald trump
vivirá como un voto de infamia en la
historia del senado de los eeuu
no hay ninguna duda de que el presidente
trump es práctica y moralmente
responsable de provocar los
acontecimientos de ese día
no hay duda al respecto las personas que
irrumpieron en este edificio creyeron
que estaban actuando según los deseos e
instrucciones de su presidente